[Musique]
ça recrute sur tv78 l'émission qui parle
d'emploi dans le département des
ivelines à chaque numéro son invité qui
vient parler de son secteur ou de son
entreprise qui recrute ambiance Noël ce
soir en plateau à quelques semaines des
fêtes de fin d'année et ce soir dans sa
recrute notre invité et Céline de carnet
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la directrice
général de l'abbaye des vaau cerna alors
c'est un ancien monastère cisterciien du
12e siècle on présentera cet endroit
assez exceptionnel dans quelques
instants c'est aujourd'hui en tout cas
un hôtel de luxe 5 étoiles et qui a
rouvert en octobre dernier et laabaye
desvern d'ailleurs un nouveau
propriétaire c'est le groupe Paris
Society est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter en quelques mots Paris Society
bienr donc Paris Society a été fondé en
2008 par Laurent de Gourcuf c'est un
lieu c'est une entreprise très festive
avec des restaurants que vous connaissez
à Paris majorité ement et qui devient un
acteur majeur de l'hospitalité en France
maintenant et donc c'est un groupe qui
recrute via l'abay des v dans au
printemps dernier vous avez lancé une
vaste campagne de recrutement avec 210
postes à pourvoir à laabay des votes
CERN il y a encore aujourd'hui une
trentaine de postes d'offre de Job
disponible l'hôtellerie restauration
c'est un secteur qui recrute et on va
justement parler avec vous aussi Clara
de Frutos bonsoir bonsoir journaliste
économique de la rédaction tv78 vous
avez sélectionné trois offres d'emploi
dans l'hôtellerie restauration sont
disponibles dès à présent dans les
ivlines oui j'ai choisi une offre
d'emploi de cuisinier de responsables de
cuisine et de mître d'hôtel et vous nous
les présenterez tout à l'heure dans sa
[Musique]
recrute direction donc l'abaye des vaau
cernet pour débuter cette émission un
endroit assez incroyable à CERN laaville
c'est niché à CERN laaville avec 900 ans
d'histoire et le lieu Céline de Carn
était à l'origine une abbaye sister
tercien est-ce que vous pouvez nous
parler un petit peu de son histoire oui
alors brièvement parce parce que c'est
c'est trop d'années à reprendre mais
bien sûr qui a été donc prise par les
moines dans les années 1100 enfin en
1100 et ensuite bien ils en ont fait un
lieu pour eux pendant 600 ans après
madame la baronne de rothschield en a
fait son lieu également d'habitation et
puis pendant après les années les
guerres n'ont pas réussi à maintenir ce
lieu malheureusement et donc nous avons
bah comme vous le voyez un lieu juste
incroyable qui est chargé d'histoire
avec des pierres incroyables ça nous a
pris 3 ans de rénovation tellement ben
on pouit pas tout bouger comme ça bien
bien là bien au contraire puisque
beaucoup de de difficulté pour faire
tout ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui en
terme de décoration la bien sûr notre il
faut je vous parle quand même de notre
décoratrice qui est Cordélia de
Castellane qui a fait un travail
incroyable de rénover tout ça en gardant
bah tout ce qui est historique et en le
rapportant avec une nouvelle touche à sa
à sa touche très féminine donc un un
vrai bijou on a vu quelques images alors
qui était et même avant les travaux on
l'a dit aujourd'hui le lieu s'est
réinventé dans une activité hôtelière
alors ça c'est vrai depuis la fin des
années 1990 et depuis peu avec le groupe
Paris Society qui on le disait le
nouveau propriétaire l'hôtel a rouvert
vous l'avez dit en octobre après 2 ans
de travaux alors aujourd'hui
concrètement l'abay de vcerné c'est quoi
il y a la partie hôtel mais aussi
plusieurs restaurants c'est ça
absolument oui donc il y a déjà nous
avons nous aurons à terme 145 chambres
aujourd'hui nous en avons 104 avec
encore une ouverture rénovation des
fermes bientôt la la ferme des vallées
qui ouvrira fin 2024 et nous avons trois
très beaux restaurants avec des
thématiques différents il y a l'auberge
une un peu plus festif un peu notre Piaf
mais à la campagne he c'est vraiment le
lieu c'est un c'est une maison de
campagne XXL pour les parisiens pour les
familles pour les couples pour tout
événement quel qu'il soit et puis
ensuite donc cette auberge qui est un
moment un peu plus festif avec un
pianiste vous avez les chasses
restauration plus française plus
semi-gastro on va dire dans un cadre
incroyable très très beau aussi et puis
le réfectoire des moines c'est là où
nous avons nos petits-déjeuner et bien
sûr ce brunch qui fait parler aussi déjà
parce que c'est gargantuesque une très
très belle offre avec des grands grands
buffets donc il a lieu le samedi et
dimanche nous avons aussi le James bar
qui est un bar à l'origine bien sûr mais
avec une restauration continue un peu
plus snacking ce type snacking qui
marche très bien également donc une
grosse activité restauration comme vous
le voyez avec donc quatre points de
vente en tout également un spa
merveilleux avec se h cabines
pardonnez-moi avec qui nous avons choisi
tata Harper comme comme marque de de
cosmétique et de soins nous avons aussi
une salle de fitness plein de loisirs
pour les enfants pour les enfants comme
les adultes la promesse c'est l'escapade
à la campagne exactement et de s'occuper
pendant 2 jours dans ce lieu qui est de
la vallée de chevruse qui est une vrai
belle campagne comme vous le savez avec
des animaux partout c'est merveilleux
mais aussi de pouvoir garder nos clients
pendant de jours jour pour qu'il
s'occupe on a un camion marécher le
dimanche une
boutique nous avons une gaming room
également un karaoké une salle de cinéma
enfin vraiment de quoi parfaitement les
occuper avec des besoins en recrutement
c'est l'objet de notre émission
d'ailleurs une question à ce sujet cl ex
oui c'est ça donc forcément vous avez
beaucoup pas beaucoup de de candidats
comment on est quand même 180
aujourd'hui donc c'est déjà un gros
Paris avec beaucoup de métiers
différents bien sûr de la hautant de la
maintenance évidemment l'hébergement les
métiers d'hébergement qui représent
quasiment la moitié à C postes près
aujourd'hui 'hui on a presque autant de
personnes qui travaillent dans la
restauration comme vous le voyez avec
tous ces points de vente et puis bien
sûr de l'hébergement du loisir du spa
qui représente la maintenance aussi de
la sécurité mais qui est sous-traité et
aussi tous nos métiers support qui nous
permettent d'être serein à nos postes
vous disant en début d'émission vous
avez lancé une vaste campagne de
recrutement au printemps 210 postes à
pourvoir est-ce que à l'image de ce que
traverse actuellement le secteur du de
l'hôtellerie restauration est-ce que
vous avez eu du mal à recruter
oui oui bien sûr mais je trouve
sincèrement qu'on s'y trouve enfin qu'on
a qu'on s'en est on a quand même de la
chance parce que quand je vois qu'on a
180 salariés dans un lieu qui est quand
même un peu excentré on loge une partie
de nos personnel aussi pour faciliter
bien sûr mais on est on est très prisé
enfin le lieu est incroyable et vous
voyez bien on a tous tendance à vouloir
un peu s'échapper loin de la ville et
c'est c'est aussi le grand attrait de
venir à la bille des vernis et aux
alentours parce que c'est une très belle
région et donc pourquoi vous avez eu des
difficultés déjà parce que je pense que
le monde de la restauration avec les
effets covid que nous avons tous connus
notamment restauration ben c'est un peu
vidé beaucoup de gens ont changé d'autes
de de métier alors que c'est un métier
absolument exceptionnel où on demande
beaucoup de compéten et beaucoup de
qualité et qui est extrêmement riche
selon moi en terme de de de qualité de
vie et de qualité de plaisir au travail
parce que surtout dans les lieux comme
ça nous avons de de très beaux lieux des
clients absolument en attente de
beaucoup de de de moments festifs a
aussi donc il y a de quoi s'amuser il y
a de quoi se faire plaisir il y a une
grande diversité de métiers famille de
métier de l'hôtellerie mais aussi de la
restauration voyez le métier de barman
dont on va parler dans un instant
absolument donc alors nous nous
recherchons essentiellement en cuisine
et en salle cuisine on a déjà une très
belle très belle équipe puisque
aujourd'hui nous avons 49 personnes en
cuisine vous imaginez c'est une très
grosse brigade qui est donc un/4 de des
clients que nous pardon des équipes que
nous avons aujourd'hui alors il juste on
voit les métiers plutôt de l'hôtellerie
main c'est l'hôtellerie absolument mais
pour la cuisine donc nous nous nous
avons des attentes en cuisine même avec
notamment des postes de chef de partie
et de comis de cuisine nous avons encore
cinq postes en cuisine à
pourvoir souvent les les les avantages
c'est aussi que ce ne sont pas on
travaille pas en coupure donc ça permet
aussi d'avoir les brigades qui ont des
moments pour eux hein parce que ça aussi
c'était un frein à la la restauration
quand on travaille en coupure c'est très
compliqué ils ont de jours de repos
souvent ensemble les deux jours juste
les fêtes là on va devoir un peu
réaménager parce qu'on a une grosse
activité et malheureusement encore pas
tous nos postes pour ça qu'on a besoin
de monde évidemment en cuisine
particulièrement et est-ce que ce sont
des posts qui nécessitent beaucoup de
compétences ou des expériences
particulières alors comis il y a quand
même un peu d'encadrement je vous cache
pas puisqueil y a des apprentis encadrés
et des des justement des chefs de chefs
de parties en casadre les comis cuisine
donc nous essentiellement trois postes
en chef de parti un poste de comis de
cuisine et pu donc là il y a un peu
d'encadrement de la gestion évidemment
et puis bien sûr du soin de de l'hygiène
ça c'est toutes les règles en cuisine
que vous connaissez parfaitement ensuite
en hébergement vous voulez que je vous
parle de l'hébergement justement oui on
a vu quelques images de du métier
d'équipier il y a aussi le métier de
femme ou Vallet de chambre est-ce que
vous pouvez présenter ce métier les les
missions les compétences requise bien
sûr absolument alors c'est vrai que
comme vous le savez les clients dans
l'hôtel leurs grandes activités ça va
être de profiter de leur chambre donc
dans un endroit parfaitement soigné et
puis bien sûr de manger donc voyez ces
deux métiers nous nous sommes nous
tiennent à cœur évidemment donc là nos
équipières mais elles sont en charge du
soin parfait autant d'hygiène de mise en
place de nos de nos chambres bien sûr de
nos suites puisque nous avons de très
belles suites et puis également ben de
veiller à on crée beaucoup de
personnalisation puisqu'on a aussi des
enfants donc plein de de soins à portés
personnels on fait une recouche le le
matin de nouveau une couverture le soir
donc encore un soin porté où on change
encore les serviettes le tout et on
remet bien propre la chambre comme en
hôtellerie de 5 étoiles il y a beaucoup
de soins beaucoup de temps à dédier à à
faire que la chambre soit parfaitement
propre bien sûr et parfaitement bien
aménagée selon nos codes selon nos
standards qui sont importants dans et
puis nos chambres sont toutes uniques
donc il y a aussi un vrai travail de de
de se remémorer où se place puis toutes
les objets de nos clients aussi dont on
prend soin et on parle de quel niveau de
rémunération pour c alorsors bien sûr
pour les chefs de parti la rémunération
est de 2500 € après pour les comis de
cuisine 2200 € alors nous cherchons
également des gouvernantes d'étages donc
là c'est c'est encore un encadrement
supérieur de nos équipiers de nos femmes
de chambre pour leur permettre ben de
coordonner le travail de la gestion du
linge la gestion bien sûr des effets
personnels des clients quand il y a des
oublis ce genre de choses donc elles ont
encore et puis des formations nos
équipes qui est très important donc no
gouvernant n nous avons un salaire à
proposer de 2800 € et puis pour les
femes des chambres 2200 € et les valet
de chambres aussi al pour parler revenir
sur le métier de barman vous aviez on a
le temps pour faire une question sur le
métier de barman Clara allez-y alors bah
quelles sont les qualités rockis pour
par barman un B barman moi je dirais
qu'il faut qu'il ait un peu d'audace
parce qu'il y a bien sûr l'exécution de
nos recettes il y a la créativité
puisqu'on a aussi nos recettes phare à
nous ce qu'on appelle nos recettes
cocktail signature mais après c'est
aussi toute l'audace à proposer autre
chose pour bah surprendre le client il y
a tout ces Gest technique aussi que vous
voyez qui sont à apprendre beaucoup de
de de personnes de recherche de
personnalisation parce que Ben nos
clients sont toujours à l'affu de
nouveautés de oui d'être surpris par nos
barmans donc ils sont ils sont en charge
et puis aussi de la restauration dans
nos espaces donc il faut on m aussi tout
ce côté restauration donc des accords ma
vin sont des sommeliers barman
restaurateurs donc il il mêent un peu
tout ça on a beaucoup d'enfants donc
aussi surprendre tous ces enfants qui
sont là et en prendre soin parce qu'on a
c'est tous ces petits là qui qui bougent
dans les salons c'est c'est un c'est un
un lieu vraiment plein de charme
dernière question comment postuler alors
comment postuler bien sûr alors là je
vous ai préparé est-ce que vous noterez
je sais pas donc on a un are site
Internet est-ce que vous pourrez le
marquer peut-être à l'antenne nous on
avait le site
carirs.paris- c'est parfait vous avez
tout à fait ça absolument et là c'est
une possibilité ou bien ainsi
directement par par email pardon c'est
recrutement @as tout simplement
àvcern.com Clara et on termine cette
émission avec vous et vous proposez à
nos téléspectateurs trois offres
d'emploi justement dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie restauration justement un
autre hôtel va ouvrir prochainement à
versaill il cherche du personnel oui
c'est l'hôtel 5 étoiles les lumières qui
cherche un maître d'hôtel en CDI à
partir du 1er avril 2024 l'établissement
devrait voir le jour en mai 2024 soit 2
mois avant le début des Jeux Olympiques
et comme vous le disiez Grégory ils
cherchent à agrandir leurs équipes pour
ouvrir dans de bonnes conditions alors
pour l'émission en tant que maître
d'hôtel vous serez amené à contribuer à
la préparation et au bon déroulement du
service à superviser les chefs de rang à
veiller à la bonne utilisation des
espaces et du matériel de travail
assurer le bien-être des clients et vous
vous serez aussi responsable de la
restauration autrement dit vous devrez
travailler dans plusieurs points clés de
l'hôtel pour ce poste il faut être
polyvalent vous avez tout compris mais
il est également demandé d'être sensible
aux questions écologiques c'est-à-dire
consommer de manière responsable réduire
la consommation de plastique de papier
et d'eau au sein de l'hôtel d'avoir une
bonne capacité relationnelle et de
maîtriser l'anglais une formation en
restauration avec idéalement une mention
supplémentaire en somellerie et demander
3 années d'expérience minimum en tant
que chef de R est un plus et pour le
salaire il peut aller jusqu'à 2600 € par
mois pour la prochaine offre vous nous
emmenez du côté de Bois d'Arcy avec une
offre d'emploi d'éior la filiale du
groupe Elior l'enseigne embauche
activement en ce moment et parmi les
offres qu'elle propose il y a celle-ci
un poste de cuisinere en CDI à bois
d'Arc alors pour ce poste vous devrez
assurer les services de nuit entre 17h
et 3h du matin vous servirez une
soixantaine de clients de couverts par
jour et vos principales missions seront
de remettre les denrées produites par
l'équipe de matin en tempér ure et au
réchauffage de réaliser des cuissons
minutes de viande et de poisson de faire
le réassort des vitrines sur le self de
procéder aux encaissements et d'assurer
le nettoyage de la cuisine et de la
plonge en fin de service autre
particularité vous travaillerez en binô
avec un autre cuisinier bon c'est un peu
comme nous en binôme sur sur sa recrute
et quelles sont les compétences requises
et ben il faut être passionné autonome
et soucieux être un bon cuisinier de
maîtriser les techniques de base en
production chaude et froide et surtout
il faudra être motivé et disponible pour
trava travailler de nuit entre 17h et 3h
du matin vous devez aussi être titulaire
d'au moins un cap beep cuisine et
d'avoir une expérience de plus de 2 ans
en cuisine et pour le salaire aucun
montant n'est spécifié alors dernière
offre d'emploi vous avez choisi un
restaurant au clés sousbois un restant
un restaurant de l'enseigne belge Léon
recherche son futur Responsable de
cuisine en CDI alors le but est
d'encadrer des équipes d'environ 10
collaborateurs et l' missions elles
seront bah de manager et motiver cette
équipe de garantir la qualité et la
régularité des produits servit au
clients de gérer et organiser la cuisine
de gérer également les commandes les
livraisons et la conformité des produits
et surtout gérer les ouvertures et les
fermeture de la cuisine dans le respect
des processus et des normes en terme de
de compétences le restaurant demande de
savoir manager une équipe de savoir
d'être passionné et d'avoir le sens du
détail d'avoir l'esprit d'équipe et pour
accom boule est en train de tomber une
boule de Noël bien sûr de notre
SAP d'avoir l'esprit d'équipe et
accompagner et former sa brigade et
avoir une énergie positive et pour pour
le salaire pareil rien n'est spécifié
sur l'offre et on précise que ces offres
d'emploi sont bien sûr consultables sur
différents sites alors vous les avez
trouvez-vous sur le site
l'hôellerie-restauration.fr et aussi sur
le portail inded on rappelle aussi qu'il
y a le site ski- Ski emploi pardon ski
emploi il y a pas tir skiemploi.fr qui
répertorie aussi les jobs disponibles
sur le territoire de Saint-Quentin en
Eveline voilà c'est la fin de sa recrute
merci de nous avoir suivi merci à vous
également Carn d'avoir été notre invité
recevoir plein candidat parce que c'est
une très belle très belle aventure je
peux vous assurer merci également à
Clara de Frutos et on se retrouve en
janvier pour un prochain numéro de sa
recrute qui prend déjà ses quartiers
d'hiver d'ici là passer d'excellentes
fêtes de fin d'année très belle soirée
sur
[Musique]
tv78